Thus far, we've seen how to design and implement
scalable algorithms that go into the guts of an
operating system for a parallel machine. Now it is
time to look at a case study of an operating
system that has been built for a shared memory
multiprocessor. This operating system is called Tornado. And the
purpose of this case study is to understand the
principles that go into the structuring of an operating system
for a shared memory multi-processor. Thus far,
we have covered a lot of ground on
parallel systems. And as a reminder, I want
to tell you that you should be reading
and understanding the papers by Merigram and Scard
on synchronization. Anderson and others on communication issues
in parallel systems, Skilante and others on scheduling
federal loans, scheduling. To get the full benefit
of all the lectures you've seen already, you definitely should
read and understand all those papers. And all these papers
are listed in the reading list for the course anyhow.
And what we're going to do now is look at how some
of the techniques that we've discussed thus far gets into
a parallel operating system. So, I'm going to look at one
or two examples of parallel operating system case studies, so
that we can understand these issues somewhat in in more detail.